as the new chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee,
you ask National Intelligence
Director Avril Haines
to assess the fallout
over the Biden document issue.
What is it
that you're most concerned about?
And has she given you an assessment
of the classified documents
that Trump had No.
And in fact,
what's really interesting here
is that in the FBI doing the raid on Mar
a Lago,
the intelligence community
and even the department
Defense was not involved at all.
And in doing any assessment
as to what the records in my Lago
might be
or even the risk associated with those
that had been surrendered
from my law,
go from former President Trump
in this instance.
Also,
they have not engaged
the intelligence community
as they were having
these documents be on a regular
basis, coughed up by President Biden
as he was finding them
in his garage behind his car in an office
he no longer occupies.
And we don't even know where he found
the other documents that had been given.
Now, what I think is important
is that because
the attorney general has gone forward
and appointed a special prosecutor
for the Biden administration,
for President Biden
on this issue, for the documents,
they're going to really important issues.
And the first issue
is a chain of custody.
These didn't start out in his garage.
They didn't start out in that office
at the PEN Biden Center.
The second thing is, is
why did the president take these?
I mean, it's
been six years
that he had these documents
when he left his vice president's office
and decided
that he was going to take
these classified documents with him.
Albeit illegally.
And as he has said, he understands that
because he says
he said that when Trump did it.
So now we now know he did it.
Why?
Six years ago
did he walk out of the vice
president's office?
Which documents are marked classified
and what did he do with them
over that six year period?
Those are all fair questions
and should be scrutinized
with that in mind,
what you just laid out,
I want to go back to what you said
in August
after the FBI search on Mar a Lago.
I interviewed you right after that.
And in that interview,
you seemed to downplay
the seriousness of classified documents
being at Mar a Lago.
Here's what you said.
In this instance, we
don't really know
that these informations are classified.
The archive is saying
that something is labeled
classified doesn't mean that it is.
We have to look at the substance
of what the president has
And we know that since then,
President Trump
has said
he had those classified folders
and so forth as keepsakes.
But it appears you've changed your tune,
saying now the discovery of Biden's
classified information would put him in
potential violation of laws
protecting national security.
So help us better understand this.
Yeah, well,
you know,
if you play just snippets
Pamela, you certainly are going to get
the context of any of our conversations.
And obviously,
the conversation was related
to President Trump.
Unlike Vice President Biden claimed
that the document
that he had
had already been declassified.
And so what I was pointing to,
which was the important issue
that you asked me in the beginning,
is that the
archivists in the FBI didn't ask
anybody in national security
or intelligence
as to what
the risk of the documents
had been surrendered.
As I just said in this interview,
or even the documents
that might likely be at the
at the Trump residence.
Now, I got to tell you, Pamela,
I've been very concerned
about the inconsistencies
that you're hearing from commentators on.
Well, Biden didn't you know, he
this was inadvertent.
He didn't mean to six years ago
walk out of the vice president's office
with these classified documents.
The concern that we all have
is the abuse of power
that was done by the Biden administration
where they raided his home.
Now, you know,
they didn't
just take classified documents
from our law.
You know,
here are the pages of the filing
of the Biden administration.
They even walked out with his
with Trump's passport.
Now, you could be an intern at the FBI.
And, you know, Trump's
passports not classified documents.
The concern here is,
is what's acceptable from our government?
Is it acceptable that they raid
a former president's home,
the political rival
for the President Biden,
and actually his announced candidate
and his likely announce candidate?
If we allow what we find acceptable
from our government
to change based on what we might Pablo,
this is important.
But if we let you finish, that's
what I think
you're missing critical information.
If if if we allow what
we find acceptable
from the government to change
based upon whether or not we like
the target of the government
or one that we believe either
religiously or politically
with that person,
we're walking away
from that
foundational principles
of our Constitution.
Right.
President Trump's House
should not have been raided.
That's the huge difference between here
and President Biden's situation.
They're allowing him to do it himself,
even with some unclassified
people who don't even have classified
ratings to be able to
to look at these documents.
This this inequality, this
this hypocritical aspect,
especially from President Biden
having condemned Trump
and then having done the same thing.
Right.
And you did I mean, he did condemn it.
And we have scrutinized that on this show
that he said it was really irresponsible
of what Trump did.
And now there have been approximately 20
classified documents
found at various properties
and certainly he has been under scrutiny.
But, you know,
if you're being intellectually honest
with yourself, the key difference here
that Trump and his team
defied a subpoena.
They said they had
turned over everything.
And yet evidence
developed through the course
of the investigation
that classified documents
were being moved,
which started this obstruction
of justice investigation.
So that is
a key difference here
of why the FBI first president
it wasn't
it wasn't an obstruction
of justice investigation. Absolutely.
That there were many.
That was my point.
My point had been and remains.
The the attorney general
had several steps
he could go through before he's
playing around.
And Melania's
clock went on for months and months
and months and months.
I mean, there was tremendous deference
they believed
and the Trump team tells you
and I don't know if it's true,
but the Trump team tells you
that there were ongoing negotiations
concerning those documents.
And the thing is,
is that
to go to the level of raiding the former
president's home,
a political rival of President Biden,
that is such a high level of scrutiny
and as you know,
they can't claim that it was
because the national security
was at risk,
because they didn't even ask
anybody who's a national security,
would you have that same reaction
if the same circumstances apply to Biden?
You would say the exact same thing.
Oh, they shouldn't
have had the same reaction.
Let's say
that's
I actually said this on Jake Tapper show.
I said, Jake,
if somebody came on and set a time
to raid their home. Yeah.
This is hypocritical
on the Biden administration.
Okay.
Thank you so much, Congressman Mike
Turner, for that spirited discussion.
This is why I like having you on.
Thank you, Pamela.
Put it all out there
and still have a civil conversation.
So appreciate your time.
And also,
I want to mention everyone,
congratulations. To you.
You just received your doctorate
from Georgetown and liberal studies.
So congratulations.